holy crap everybody it actually looks
like we might be getting a version of
Batman on Titan season 1 in I think a
lot of you probably already connected
the dots like hey if we have Robin that
how can you do that without doing Batman
so I think a lot of people expected the
character to appear in some way but you
just don't know how they're gonna handle
it until you hear some casting
announcements and you start seeing stuff
from behind the scenes so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there's gonna be a whole bunch more
tight and stuff dropping now that
they're actually shooting episodes and
we might actually get to see some
footage before the end of the year
depending on how quickly they're
proceeding through the first couple of
episodes the reason why you've been
seeing all these websites reporting that
Batman might be on Titan season 1 is
because of two particular casting
notices that they just put up so these
would be characters that we show up in
the first half of the season there's a
character called young John Crosland
who's basically like their young version
of Nightwing the Robin age version of
Nightwing male Caucasian to play ages 10
to 13 athletic lean approximately 5 feet
tall in not afraid of heights please
list height on submission so I mean
they're looking for somebody that's
relatively small compared to who this
flashback Batman is going to be so
automatically you read that and you're
like hey wait a minute that sounds like
they're doing the arrow thing where they
flashback to his time before the island
except Robin's island was his time with
Batman his crucible that he went through
where he learned how to be a detective
he learned how to fight crime he gained
all these skills so it sounds like we'll
have our Dick Grayson and present-day
that's on his way to becoming Nightwing
and he'll flashback remember his time
with Batman and we'll actually see that
and he'll use the lessons that he
learned while he was with Batman and
apply it to present-day problems like if
they go full Chuck Dixon Nightwing and
he's a detective during the day you can
see him working on a case thinking about
his time with the world's greatest
detective and then whatever that lesson
is they'll just show it in a flashback
scene with this young John Crosland 13
year old kid and the other character
which it sounds like their younger
version of Batman it says Dave's story
is the fake name that they're using it
says male mid 30s to 40s Caucasian the
downfalls of others only make this man
stronger
polished unwavering think a young Jack
Nicholson recurring guest star so one
that just sounds like a middle-aged
version of Batman
so using Christopher Nolan era Batman to
chart the timeline just his character
development between his 20s as 30s and
then his 40s which is the Ben Affleck
version of the character during the
events of Batman Begins in the Dark
Knight he's still in his 20s like late
20s by the end of the Dark Knight during
Dark Knight Rises not that much time has
passed but he looks like he's closer to
his mid-30s it's just that he has the
body of a 50 year old because his time
as a crime fighter has been so hard on
him like he's so broken down that's why
he has to wear the special harness to
defeat Bane they took it pretty real in
that but the Ben Affleck version of the
character is a 40-something Batman so
think somebody between the ages of
Christian Bale and Ben Affleck just as
look on-screen so it makes sense that he
would have had a Robin during that
period because even if you take Batman V
Superman as canon he has a Robin costume
it's implied that he may have died they
never really clarified that too much and
they kind of pushed it off to the side
because we have a Nightwing in the DC EU
now that we'll be finding out about next
year so Dick Grayson is still alive
somewhere in the DC EU but the main
takeaway is that their approach to the
Batman character is that it'll be in
flashbacks arrow style and I'm gonna be
really cautiously optimistic about this
and say that we won't see him in the
Batman costume right away
we'll see Bruce Wayne flashbacks with
Robin and they'll be talking to each
other he'll be giving him lessons he'll
be watching Batman solve crimes and then
maybe by the end of the season maybe
we'll get to see a version of the Batman
costume on TV because it is a huge deal
that they're getting this close to an
actual Batman on TV a modern version of
Batman because we did have the Adam West
TV version and we do have a Bruce Wayne
on Gotham but he's nowhere near putting
the costume on in the way that show
treats the character isn't totally
authentic to the comics they really bend
time and space like genuinely he
shouldn't be becoming the Batman until
he's in his mid-20s and this kid looks
like he's maybe 16 or 17 these
flashbacks line up with some of the
other casting announcements that we've
heard they're casting the flying
Grayson's meaning that we'll be getting
other Nightwing flashbacks or Robin
flashbacks to his
before he met Batman so what they might
do in the first two or three episodes is
just tell his complete origin story in a
series of flashbacks
so arrow season one style you really
start with a character in present-day
and then you flash back to how he got on
the island so think of it as a similar
treatment for the Nightwing character
you pick up with him in present day
before he's taken the Robin costume off
kicking ass in Gotham as he heads off to
whatever life he's going to make for
himself in Bludhaven but then he
encounters problems that make him
remember his time with Batman he thinks
about his time with his family so you
get to see all the different versions of
the character up to present day and it
should go without saying because we saw
Brenton Thwaites in the Robin costume
that's probably from a scene in
present-day in the early episodes so he
hasn't become Nightwing yet at the very
beginning of the show and it's probably
a result of his time with the Titans and
the lessons that he learns over the
course of season one that inspire him to
become that character but the whole
thing about him choosing the actual
Nightwing name is actually inspired by a
Superman mythology by Nightwing in flame
bird so I'll be interested to see how
they explained the Nightwing name once
he eventually takes it up but we don't
know exactly when that's going to happen
because even cooler than that is that we
learn about Donna Troy just a little
while ago I think I added her to my last
Titans video there's a casting
announcement that sounds like they're
doing Donna Troy but she'll be more of a
season 2 character and we'll only see
her a couple times during season 1 but
that gets into Wonder Woman mythology so
if they're already doing Batman and
Wonder Woman mythology then it's a fair
bet that they'll get to a lot of
Superman stuff too but there's still a
lot of questions because the show is
happening on a different earth like
arrow reference Bruce Wayne so there is
a version of Bruce Wayne on earth 1 and
they made references to the
reverse-flash fighting Superman so that
also means that there's a Krypton
there's Superman Supergirl in the earth
1 universe we just haven't met them yet
the Titans characters might also cast
different versions of those big a
listers so we might see a different
Bruce Wayne when he eventually makes
himself known on arrow which I think
will happen if the show can make it a
couple more years I think they will get
to an eventual Bruce Wayne appearance no
promises on an actual bat
costume on the CW shows we'll see about
that that feels like it's way further
off
I think Titans has a much better chance
of actually putting Bruce Wayne in a
Batman costume just because of the
characters that they're already doing I
mean you're doing Dick Grayson Robin
Nightwing you have to do Batman at some
point it's just a no-brainer well let me
know in the comments what do you think
about the idea of the Titans TV show
taking the arrow flashback approach to
doing the Batman character I feel like
any version of it as long as it's cool
will be awesome people just want to see
an awesome version of Batman on TV
that's all we want there's a new round
of that blasts ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter just be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from the
last video lovely wolf please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there'll be a new round when I
post new DC a lot of comic book stuff
coming between Star Wars videos this
week click here for my non-spoilery Star
Wars the last Jedi review and click here
for my Titan season 1 flash Wally West
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight